now i wanted to do this video on
magnesium because it relates to another
topic that i'm studying now on
chlorophyll which is the green stuff or
the blood of the plant when a plant is
deficient in chlorophyll the leaves turn
yellow and one cause of that is a
magnesium deficiency chlorophyll being
the blood of the plant
is similar in chemistry to our own blood
yet we have iron to make it red plants
have magnesium to make the leaves green
so we can have chlorosis in plants which
could be a magnesium deficiency as well
as chlorosis in humans
which is anemia where a person can
actually
look a little green and magnesium is a
very very important mineral it's in hard
water okay you have calcium and
magnesium it's in a very absorbable form
it's in bicarbonate okay when you heat
water
those bicarbonates turn into a carbonate
form which makes them absorb less in our
bodies and you would see it when you
make your tea when you heat your water
you'll see these white little specks at
the bottom of the pot so our bodies do
absorb these bicarbonates
very easily so hard water
mineral water great source of magnesium
as well as calcium and of course when
you soften the water you take out these
minerals so there's some really
interesting studies that show that hard
water is actually very very good
for your cardiovascular system and soft
water is not now one little side note
about
that condition called chlorosis in
plants one way to develop this condition
is to over water the plants because all
these minerals can leach out
same thing happens when we drink too
much water especially without minerals
we dilute the minerals we have in our
body and that creates all sorts of
issues with our heart with our nerves
and muscles however if you if you're not
drinking hard water or
mineral water get your magnesium from
leafy greens
of course an average person only
consumes like one and a half cups of
vegetables per day but you definitely
want to beef that up
i want to talk about some very
surprising
symptoms
and
unique benefits of magnesium okay number
one magnesium relieves muscle tightness
we know that magnesium deficiencies will
create cramps of the muscles but if you
have tight muscles which is different
than a cramped muscle that can be a
magnesium deficiency number two
magnesium is intimately involved in
making atp that's the energy currency of
the body so your energy level is
dependent on magnesium if you don't have
enough you're going to be kind of tired
all the time all right number three
magnesium helps vitamin d's
bioavailability
you need magnesium to allow vitamin d to
work so if you're deficient in magnesium
you can take all this vitamin d and it
doesn't seem to work and as a side note
if you want a really good form of
magnesium
i'm going to put a link down below as
well as a good source of vitamin d with
magnesium i'll put that link down below
too all right number four
magnesium prevents calcium
from depositing in the wrong places in
your body so it works similar to vitamin
k2 all right number five magnesium
relieves migraines number six
having enough magnesium will support
your friendly bacteria if someone is
magnesium deficient like
two-thirds of the world's population
that can negatively affect the
microbiome the friendly bacteria all
right number seven with enough magnesium
you can avoid having pins and needles
and numbness that type of thing either
in your lips your fingers or the bottom
of your feet which is called paresthesia
and number eight
let's say your cortisol is high and that
affects your sleep patterns
magnesium can help so magnesium is very
important in the regulation of cortisol
so excessive cortisol symptoms
could be a magnesium deficiency
this is why magnesium helps people with
stress and number nine having enough
magnesium will keep your parathyroid
functioning at its optimum level the
parathyroid hormone helps to regulate
calcium so if you're low in calcium
the parathyroid hormone will increase to
help elevate calcium well guess what if
you're deficient in magnesium the
parathyroid hormone will also increase
to help you retain more magnesium so any
symptoms where you have high parathyroid
hormone could be
a magnesium deficiency all right and so
the question is how do you become
deficient in magnesium well you don't
need enough leafy greens number one
fluoride consumption in tap water
can create a magnesium deficiency
fluoride medications can also do it
refined grains refined sugars will
create a deficiency low hydrochloric
acid in your stomach can create a
problem stress will do it being a
diabetic can create a deficiency this is
why magnesium is so important to
stabilize your blood sugars
alcohol can create a deficiency and if
you have a malabsorption of your gut
okay
now there's quite a few medications that
can also create a deficiency of
magnesium um diuretics ppis or antacids
statins antibiotics as well as birth
control pills now if you haven't seen
this video on magnesium this is a very
very important one check it out i put it
right here